[Music]
star versus the forces of evil is an
awesome show we all love star butterfly
and we think she is definitely Disney
Princess material you literally won't
believe the original pitch for the show
stay tuned until the end to find out
just how different star almost was if
this is your first time visiting the
things smash that subscribe button to
stay in the loop don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up now let's get
started with the ten reasons why star
butterfly is actually a Disney Princess
she speaks up for herself all Disney
Princesses share some common traits one
of these is that they aren't afraid to
speak up for themselves
[Music]
in fact the plot of most Disney Princess
movies depends on it
I lied we could never have won the heart
of Jasmine if she just done as her
father said and married someone she
didn't love Ariel wouldn't be herself if
she didn't tell her father who she was
and what she wanted every Disney
Princess got to where she is by sticking
up for herself and what she believes him
Star has no problem telling anyone where
she stands on anything she'll defend her
opinion in any situation with no fear of
the consequences
can you imagine Star not telling little
off or refusing to give it to Marco
straights no way she's a girl with
conviction and she's not ashamed to talk
about it she's not even afraid to stick
up to her royal parents she'll say it
like it is and stand up for what she
thinks is right it's that kind of
conviction and bravery that make her a
Disney princess in our hearts she's the
star every character considered a Disney
princess is the star of their story
Pocahontas may not have been an actual
princess but the story revolved around
her she was the primary focus and that
gave viewers time to get to see why she
deserved to be considered a princess the
same can be said of Mulan being the main
character in her film is what gave the
audience time to see what she was made
of a Disney Princess is nothing without
her fans and their love a character
needs a lot of screen time to develop
that kind of following minor characters
are never considered princesses even if
they are daughters of the raw
Bill's star definitely fits this
criterion this show was also named after
her star is the center of every plot in
every episode her antics and ambitions
fuel every story
snow-white set the standard for all
future Disney Princesses she was the
star of the story and the titular
character just like Elora in Sleeping
Beauty it's all about the star and star
versus the forces of evil since the show
is all about the star we get plenty of
chances to see all of the traits that
make her an excellent Disney Princess
she's no minor character to be forgotten
she takes center stage she wasn't
introduced in a sequel there are plenty
of Disney characters who are the
daughters of royalty and are still not
considered Disney Princesses for some
that's because they were introducing
sequels of other films characters
introduced in sequels are considered
supporting characters to a franchise a
perfect example of this is princess
melody
she's the royal daughter Prince Erik and
Ariel both of her parents have their own
crown before they met and married you
would think that that kind of background
would seal the deal for melodie
unfortunately for her her arrival in the
Little Mermaid too disqualifies her from
the title being of royal birth isn't
everything when it comes to being a
Disney Princess if melody had been born
at the end of the first film she still
wouldn't have been the star it seems she
was doomed from the start at least she
has a great life to make up for not
being considered at Disney Princess
there are plenty of official Disney
Princesses who were never even nobility
some came from cultures that didn't even
have the princesses like Pocahontas the
fact that there were no Native American
princesses hasn't stopped the world from
embracing Pocahontas as a Disney royal
her film was an original work and she
was the star so she fits the bill stars
show isn't a sequel either it's not even
a spinoff it's a completely original
work which means she isn't automatically
disqualified from the title star versus
the forces of evil is a standalone
franchise she's performed acts of
heroism one thing that all Disney
Princesses have in common is that
they've done something heroic star
is no stranger to dangerous situations
her life is all about defending the
dimension from Ludo his monsters and all
kinds of bad guys she's performed so
many acts of heroism that we couldn't
even list them all how many times has
she defended her just like Mulan the
star has earned the honor with bravery
and selflessness who long was not born
to royalty and she wasn't even nobility
she lived a simple life on the farm
before fate called to her when her
injured father was called the war move
on did what all Disney princesses do she
answered the call of duty she tied up
her hair put on her father's armor and
marched off to war she trained hard to
keep her secrets and was instrumental in
defeating the Huns without her China
would be doomed
Pocahontas also won her place in the
princess line up with her heroic deeds
she defended her people and dared to act
as an ambassador she prevented a war and
saved countless lives princesses of
rural marriage have been heroic to fell
bravely offered to stay with beasts in
his castle if he would only let her
father go that selfless act saved her
father's life and set the rest of the
film in motion
she was heroic again when she saved
beasts from an angry mob her love of
beasts broke the curse and transformed
him into her prince every princess is a
hero in the Disney Universe star
performs acts of heroism every day which
makes her princess material she's brave
you can't speak up for yourself or
perform an act of heroism if you don't
have courage bravery is one trait that
all Disney Princesses must possess star
isn't afraid to move to an alternative
dimensions and deliver her own well
Marco looks like I'm just a skimmer
skimming the surface of the hobo gravy
what most kids have a hard time leaving
for summer camp if that isn't brave
enough for you she also defends our
entire dimension from multiple forces of
evil it's obvious the girls got guts the
Disney princess who came before her set
a high bar for this trace Snow White
faced an evil queen who tried to kill
her during the entire film she was
tricked poisoned and attacked the Evil
Queen even set a grown man after her
literally out for snow white's hearts
can you imagine having the courage to
face those odds Cinderella had the deck
stacked against her just as high she was
trapped by an abusive family that
treated her like a servant when she lost
her father she lost her last sources
supports and encouragement she had the
bravery to stand up for herself against
her own family and found a way to escape
Mulan couldn't have saved all of China
if she weren't brave stars fearless
courage makes her a powerful princess
she's just as courageous as any Hun
defeating Beast confronting war
preventing princess in the Disney lineup
she's strong the best part of being a
Disney Princess is that you don't need
anyone to come to your rescue in fact a
lot of Disney Princesses rescue others a
classic example is Ariel in the Little
Mermaid after a horrible shipwreck her
human love interest is cast overboard
Erik is undoubtedly doomed to drowned
until Ariel intervenes she saves the
sinking prince from a watery grave and
helps him back to shore
erik catches the quick glimpse of his
hero before she swims back to her
kingdom and their love story is set in
motion cinderella displays an entirely
different kind of strength not only did
she carry on after losing her beloved
father but she survived to the years of
torture her stepmother and stepsisters
put her through after she woke up day
after day knowing nothing but chores and
misery would meet her she never gave up
and eventually escaped star is just as
strong high school is a smooth
experience for anyone facing the
challenge of high school in another
dimension stuns really scary star rises
to the challenge and embraces the new
experience she isn't afraid to become
friends with Marco and proves her
strength against Pluto and the forces of
evil over and over
stars one tough princess and she isn't
afraid to show it
she definitely belongs in the ranks of
Mulan Pocahontas and Belle all of these
lovely ladies have shown just how strong
they are she's intelligent Disney
Princesses are some smart cookies
considered Pocahontas she survives with
limited technology and resources she's
basically the Bear Grylls of Disney
Princesses she can't just buy a book on
survival skills or google animal plans
in her area Pocahontas has to have all
of that knowledge and in from
in her head that takes some serious
brains she also successfully managed
relations between her people and the
English diplomacy isn't easy and takes a
lot of wits bail is also a brainy beauty
she spends all of her time reading and
remembers a lot of what she learns her
eyes lit up when she saw beasts library
star easily stacks up to the other
princesses with her skills and know-how
she's not just a pretty interdimensional
face
she's a strategic genius even if her
grades may have slipped here or there
she has a problem outsmarting the bad
guys she takes a page from Mulan whose
brilliant battle strategies saved her
entire country Disney Princesses are
kind of unstoppable Tiana from The
Princess and Frog is a financial and
business genius
she plans and launches her own
restaurant that's no easy task
star is definitely in good company when
it comes to smart if you're looking for
a group of impressive and intelligent
girls then Disney Princesses are a great
place to begin she's kind stars a sweet
girl she totally deserves her princess
title based on kindness alone no Disney
princess would fit the role without
using sweetness Cinderella was kind to
the mice and her very undeserving family
Pocahontas was sympathetic to the
English visitors when most of her people
were shy and wary for open mind and the
cart helped avoid a huge disaster Snow
White was so sweet even the forest
creatures trusted and refriended her
that's a whole lot of lovely star proves
her kindness over and over
she's been willing to sacrifice for the
good of others and isn't even mean to
Bluto she came to another dimension with
an open mind and was ready to make
friends and try new things right away
she's a fearless warrior when she met
her roommate Marcos she was kind to him
even when he showed more fear than she
did he also said he couldn't live under
the same roof to star she didn't take it
personally and worked harder to earn his
respect
she's definitely sweet enough to be a
Disney Princess Mulan was even kind
enough to her buddies in training while
she listened to their rude opinions that
took a lot of kindness star is obviously
nailing this trait of a Disney Princess
she's curious this trait of a Disney
princess is essential without a hunger
knowledge thou wouldn't always have her
nose in a book she wouldn't have spent
all that time getting through beasts
grumpy exterior without being curious as
to who he really was she would never
have found the enchanted Rose either it
was her curiosity about humans that led
ariel to amass the vast collection of
stuff it drew her closer to Eric and led
her to save his life but star isn't an
entirely new dimension she can't help
but be curious about everything around
her there's new food friends animals and
places to explore she has to learn an
entirely new culture the fact that she
faces all of these changes with
excitement shows how curious she is she
can't wait to get to know Marco her new
school or triangle foods that curiosity
is what drives the princess to see
what's just around the Riverbend without
it what would keep them exploring and
adding to their stories we think star
has all the thirst for adventure and
knowledge necessary to make her a great
Disney Princess her show is a success
one of the criteria to be a Disney
princess is that the character must be
from a title that's a major box-office
hit star isn't from a future film which
is the only legitimate argument against
her being a Disney Princess but it
doesn't even make a difference I'm still
gonna be queen it may not be a feature
film but the show has enjoyed tremendous
success not only was the show loved by
fans but it's also loved by Disney
before the first episode ever aired on
Disney XD the show was already renewed
for a second season the channel has
always loved the show from the first day
it was pitched the creator Darrin FC had
a much different idea of who star
butterfly would be before the show was
produced
she wrote a character with no magical
abilities and an overactive imagination
Disney execs are known for thinking
outside the box and quickly came up with
a better idea they suggested that star
would be a better role model to young
women if she actually had the power she
fantasized about hens they were right we
hope you loved hearing all of the
reasons why star is totally a Disney
Princess let us know in the comments
what you think about star joining the
Disney princess list we'll see you later
[Music]